The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We had a staff
meeting yesterday, and we
decided that what we're going
to do is, we'll start with
defects and solids.
We didn't examine you on it
with the last celebration.
So we'll pick it up with
defects, and we'll go through
to the end of solutions,
acid-bases.
So the stuff that we covered on
Monday, the nomenclature of
organics, we're going
to leave out.
Because you don't have enough
time with the recitations to
really dig into that,
and I think it's--
with the test being on a Monday
this time, and not on a
Wednesday, the schedule is
little bit of out of balance
from the way I'd
like it to be.
But I thought having the third
celebration the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving
was not wise.
I know that a number of you
are going to be in transit
that on Wednesday.
But let me remind you that
Wednesday, we will have a
full-blown lecture.
I'm going without
any slow down.
So next Wednesday, we will
start biochemistry.
So those of you who are not
here, please make sure that
you have viewed the lecture.
Because when you return on
Monday, you will have no idea
what's going on.
And it'd be a good idea not to
blow biochemistry, because on
the final exam--
if you fail the final,
it's not good.
It's really not good.
So just to be clear, we're going
to start with defects
and solids, and go through, and
end with acids, bases, and
solution chemistry.
OK.
So today I want to start to get
some mileage out of what
we learned on Monday.
I want to talk today about one
of the applications of organic
chemistry, and that's
polymers.
So we're going to take two
lectures on polymers, and then
we'll feed into biochemistry,
and you'll see a very natural
progression from what we're
doing now into the
biochemistry.
So let's begin with a little
bit of reflection on what
we've done so far.
Up until now, we've looked at
various solid structures.
We've started with single atoms.
We looked at crystals,
disordered crystals,
and so on.
We've looked at compounds,
and we've even
looked at small change.
We looked at alkanes,
straight chain
alkanes, branched alkanes.
And we've looked at
network solids.
Here is a regular network.
This is the structure of
graphite, for example.
Nice, ordered crystalline
structure.
Diamond grows in three
dimensions without abatement.
We've looked at disordered
networks,
such as silicate glasses.
So that's what we've looked
at up until now.
What I want to talk about
today is polymers.
Polymers are macromolecules.
These are long chain
molecules.
By long, we're talking about
thousands and thousands of
repeat units.
And this is the distinguishing
feature between macromolecules
that are found in
the body, versus
macromolecules that are man-made.
Mother Nature is a
polymer engineer.
We are a macromolecular
organism.
This is all polymer.
It's all polymer.
The changes in shape is all
elasticity in a polymer.
And inside, of course, I've got
a ceramic skeleton, which
keeps the frame in place.
But this is all polymers.
But the difference here is,
this is not a repeat unit.
Whereas when we have a man-made
structure, it's the
same repeating chemical
structure.
And the other thing I want to
say at the beginning is their
importance in commerce.
Polymers are found
everywhere today.
Trash bags, auto parts.
And in culture, they're
absolutely
essential to culture.
Let's think about it.
When you play that DVD, that
DVD is information
embedded in a polymer.
The magnetic drags.
What are magnetic drags?
These are polymers that have
been coated with gammaferic
oxide or some other
magnetic material.
Without polymers we couldn't
have the modern era.
And if you go back before the
DVD, with the CD, before that
was magnetic tape and
cassette, and
before that was this.
You might see some
of these around.
This is an old way of
presenting musical
information.
This is the phonograph record,
photograph recording.
And this is information that is
scribed into a platter, and
it's made of polyvinyl
chloride.
That's why you hear
the term vinyl.
Why is Virgin, the big Virgin
enterprise, called Virgin?
Because Virgin Records, when
they made their platters, they
started with virgin vinyl,
not recycled polymer.
And so their platters would
lie flat on the turntable.
Whereas some of them you
buy, you put them
down, and they warp.
It's OK, because the needle
would still track, but it
looked kind of--
playing like this.
And it's too bad that
we've lost this.
Because this gives rise to the
real estate possibility for
artwork, and liner notes, and so
on, that you don't get when
you download something
for $0.99.
OK?
So an electromechanical device
moves along here, and jiggles
in the grooves, and those
mechanical wigglings get
converted into energy that
ultimately gets fed through
the loudspeakers.
And now let's talk about
visual information.
Daguerre invented halide
photography in the early
1800s, but we didn't get
motion pictures.
Cinematography had to wait for
the advent of polymers,
because only when we could make
material that would come
out miles long on which we
could coat with halide
photosensitive emulsion, could
we imagine images flashing
past us faster than the
persistence of vision.
You need-- what's the
persistence of vision?
Around a twentieth
of a second.
Motion pictures are 24
frames a second.
So you couldn't have glass
plates on which you've got
halide film zipping past
at 24 frames a
second for 90 minutes.
So only with the advent of
polymers did we have the birth
of cinematography.
So what I'm talking about
here changed the world.
It changed the world, and gives
birth to the fantastic
access that we have
to information.
And now, of course, as things
move digitally, and they
dematerialize, you're going
to see a shift away.
But all this stuff was
enabled by the
advent of polymer chemistry.
So with that as a motivator,
let's dive in.
This is good stuff.
It's really, really good.
So now the payback comes.
You know, all those little
lessons about, where's the
electron, where's the orbital,
you know, who wants to learn
that stuff.
You have to learn it!
If you're going to write the
great novel, you've got to
learn how to spell.
All right.
So let's go.
So the polymer, it comes
from the Greek poly,
meaning may, right?
Poly is many And the mer,
the mer is this repeat
unit, if you like.
Many units, many units.
So let's take a simple
example.
Last day we studied
polyethylene.
So polyethylene looks
like this.
Double bond, one, two, three,
four, four hydrogens.
So this is just ethylene.
And what I can do with ethylene,
is I can react it.
Ethylene's a gas, room
temperature.
Put it into a reactor and expose
it to an initiator.
And the initiator
is a radical.
You know what the radical.
It's something that's got
this unpaired electron.
It's very active.
And the radical sees a unit of
ethylene, which I'm going to
write like this.
We don't need to put the
120 degrees now.
And what the ethylene does, is
this radical attacks this
double bond and figures, well,
it's better to have two single
bonds than one double bond.
Reacts the double bond,
breaks it, and
then forms the following.
The radical now bonds to the
ethylene, breaks that double
bond, and transfers the unpaired
electron to the end.
But now this thing is itself a
radical, and it's swimming in
a gas of ethylene.
So now a second C2H4 comes up
against this, and it's turned
into the following, are now C
C C C C, one, two, three,
four, one, two, three, four.
And so on.
And this can go without limit,
until we shut down the
reactor, or we introduce
something that terminates,
that will cap this.
All right?
So this is the beginning
of it.
And what you see is attachment,
attachment,
attachment, breaking
of double bonds.
And so we have a repeat
unit here.
This repeat unit, the mer unit,
is this ethylene unit,
and it can go to a value of
n that is very, very high.
What kind of numbers can
we expect to get?
We can have numbers here
where n takes values--
and these aren't hard and fast,
but just to give you
some idea--
you could have a, you know the
oxymoron jumbo shrimp.
You could have a short
chain polymer.
A short chain, long chain.
You know?
Boy, you're really dead today.
What's the matter with you?
Sleep deprived?
You've--
All right.
So n can go up to
about 10,000.
Now what's the atomic mass of
this, just as representative?
This is 2 times 12 is 24,
25, or 26, 27, 28.
28's roughly 30, so 30 times
10,000, you've got 300,000.
That's 300,000 grams per mole.
This means you can have
molecular weights on the order
of a million grams per mole
for one molecule.
And by the way, the polymer
people, they come from a
different branch of science.
So they don't use this
grams per mole.
Instead of grams per mole, they
like to use the word, the
dalton, as a unit of measure.
So you might see in the pollymer
literature, you'll
see the polymer with so many
kDa, kilodaltons, thousands of
grams per mole.
That's the nomenclature
you will see.
OK.
Now, what are the properties of
these things going to be?
Oh wait, I'm going to
show you something.
To give you a sense.
You need to be awakened.
So let me give you a sense
of just how long
these molecules are.
So I'm going to give you a
little mechanical model here.
I'm going to put up here
so we get some--
So what I've got here is
just a pull chain.
If you go in the basement, you
might see these pull chains.
They're just made of brass,
little brass balls, and then
they've got links
between them.
And when you cut them-- you buy
them by the foot at the
hardware store.
You put it on a light, you can
turn the light on and off by
toggling up and down.
So I'm going to say, let's say
this distance here represents
the distance between
mer units.
This distance could be
between 2 mer units.
And I figured, let's see,
I've got 40 feet here,
and I did the math.
So this thing here, with the
40 foot pull chain, has a
polymerization index--
let's call this the
polymerization index.
So my polymerization index, I
calculated it for this thing.
It's on the order
of about 3,000.
So that's pretty good.
It's right in the
middle of this.
It's actually--
this qualifies as a
bona fide polymer.
So let's take a look at
what happens here.
This is one molecule.
So what do you know about
interactions between molecules?
Now, in the liquid state,
what's this going to be?
Is it going to be fluid, or
is it going to be viscous?
It's going to be viscous.
Look, this is one molecule, and
it entangles with itself.
Now, to make a liquid, I have
thousands of these things
swimming around, above their
crystallization--
oh, crystallization
temperature.
Freudian slip.
Above their solidification
temperature.
When they solidify,
are they going to
form an ordered solid?
One of these at each
lattice site?
Probably not.
They're probably going to
form disordered solids.
So most of the polymers that
we encounter are probably
going to be disordered.
How is this held together
when it forms a solid?
It's polyethylene.
Well, what's your menu?
Is it ionic bonding?
Is it metallic bonding?
Is it hydrogen bonding?
How is it held together?
Weak van der Waals.
Weak van der Waals bonds.
But look at the surface area.
So this is what it looks like.
See, and it entangles, is even
entangles with my clothing.
It just grabs onto everything.
All right.
Actually, why don't we--
David, let's cut
to the screen.
So here we are.
This is it.
This is the polymer.
And every once in a while,
a polymer will do
something like this.
It'll say, you know, I still,
even though I'm in this big
long chain molecule I still
want to try to order.
Because I read in 3091 that
ordering lowers the free
energy of the system...
So what it does, it
starts doing this.
And can you see when it starts
doing this, that it
starts to take on--
if you walked into the room
just now, and this were
blowing up really high, you
might see just this little
snippet and say, wow.
This thing is starting to look
like a cubic array isn't it?
This is a really good model.
It's a really good model,
because this
is what really happens.
And so that decreases the
energy of the system.
The bonds are greater there.
So what's that going to do to
the mechanical properties?
Going to strengthen it, yeah.
It's going to make
things stiffer.
Instead of being this soft,
squishy polymer, it's going to
have some stiffness to it.
And you've come up across
that stuff.
The most notable one
being the CD case.
The people that make those, I'd
like to bring them here
and sit them down and teach
them some polymer science.
Those things are so brittle.
They crack, right?
There's only two classes
of jewel cases.
Those that are cracked, and
those that will crack.
Because these people don't
know what they're doing.
OK.
So now let's have some
time here to codify
what we've just see.
So first of all, we suspect that
they're going to be solid
at room temperature.
Dominantly.
We can engineer them to be
liquid, but dominantly solid
at room temperature.
And van der Waals
bonds abundant.
OK.
And the liquid, as a liquid,
we expect viscous liquid.
Good.
Got that down.
What else to have to know?
Let's do calculation here.
So I did one here where I said,
what's this distance?
We saw last day that this
distance, carbon-carbon,
remember, we're looking at
single bond, double bond.
A single bond carbon-carbon is
about 1.5 angstroms. So this
is 1.5 angstroms. The distance
between successive mer units
is about 3 angstroms. And so
if you take something 3
angstroms, and you make it this
number of mer units, I
came up with a polymerization
index of 3571 when this thing
weighs 10,010 kilodaltons.
And so then that means that
you'd end up with a length,
molecular length is on the order
of 10,714 angstroms,
which is on the order of 1
micrometer, which then makes
it greater than the wavelength
of visible light.
So this is really a different
type of matter.
And we can go there.
We've talked about viscous, so
I'm going to remind you of two
observations here.
Viscous liquids, amorphous
solids.
If you put those two ideas
together, what
else can we call upon?
We can go back to this.
Yeah.
Remember this?
What's this?
This is super-cool liquid,
super-cool viscous liquid.
This is the solidification
temperature, which in the case
of liquid to amorphous solid
is the glass transition
temperature.
And here we have the excess
volume, right?
This is the volume, and then
there's some crystalline
volume, and so on.
Right?
I can cool at a second
rate, and I get this.
So this is slow cool,
this is fast cool.
We have a Tg up here.
Tgf I'll call Tg fast,
and Tgs, Tg slow.
So that'll give me a
different volume.
So this is volume fast
and volume slow.
All right?
And since I know that density is
equal to mass over volume,
so therefore v fast
is greater than--
I observe v fast is greater
than v slow, so therefore
density of the fast cool must
be less than the density of
the slow cool.
Now I'm going to put
some names on here.
I'm going to call this the
cooling curves for
polyethylene.
These are the cooling curves
for polyethylene.
So this, down here, gives me--
this is now high-density
polyethylene, and up here is
low-density polyethylene.
Same thing, just different
processing.
So faster cooling quenches
in more free volume.
And since volume is a measure
of disorder, right?
What's the difference between
great disorder and
not-so-great disorder?
David, again cut to the
projector, please?
Forgive me, the document
camera?
So the difference between
high disorder and
low disorder is this.
This is the order, here.
So what that tells me is that in
high-density polyethylene,
there is a greater percentage
of zones like this.
And we just reasoned that this
is going to give stiffness and
so on, and sure enough, for the
low-density polyethylene,
low-density polyethylene is used
in things like food wrap,
things like stretch and seal,
where you can pull because you
can move those macromolecules
relative to one another
without fracturing the material
to stretch it over.
Whereas the high-density
polyethylene is used in such
things as milk jugs,
where you want a
little bit of stiffness.
Polyethylene milk jugs are
still kind of floppy, but
there's a little bit
of stiffness to it.
The other thing is, because the
low-density polyethylene
is dominantly amorphous, with
almost none of this second
zone here, it's transparent
to visible light.
But now, let's think about
what's going on here.
Where I've got this chain,
and then all of a
sudden I get to this.
All right?
So this is clear
and colorless.
Right?
It's a high band gap material.
There's no free electrons.
It's going to be transparent
to invisible light.
So this is transparent to
visible light all along.
But can you see that because I
have this zone of ordering,
the density of matter here is
different, and so therefore,
when a photon comes in, the
index of refraction--
now, you know, this is one
of those days where n is
going to come up.
So here n is the polymerization
index.
Here it's index of refraction.
So maybe we'll use a
different color.
How about that.
All right?
So the green n is index
of refraction.
So the index of refraction
in the amorphous zone, is
different from the index of
refraction in the partially
crystalline zone.
So index of refraction varies
from zone to zone.
Even though each zone is clear
and colorless, can you see
that this boundary between the
ordered and in the disordered
zone acts like an interface?
And what happens when you have
an interface with a different
index of refraction?
It scatters light.
And as a result, the milk
jugs, they appear white.
You can't see through them,
even though they're
constituted of the same
continuous material.
But there's these density
fluctuations, because this is
a higher density than this.
So you can rationalize
all of this stuff.
OK.
So this is what we would
call partial
crystallization in this zone.
And that gives rise
to the changes.
Now, how would we distinguish
these?
What technique would I use to
see if I've got order in this
polymer, that I don't
know anything about?
How do I interrogate
atomic order?
What technique would I use?
X-ray defraction.
Thank you.
Back to the slides,
please, David.
I'll find you the piece.
This is called polyethylene,
but remember last day, the
IUPAC notation for this
is ethyne, so
this becomes polythene.
And in the UK, it's known as
polythene, and there's a
Beatles song, Polythene Pam.
The only reason--
I put up here for two reasons.
One is, it has something
to do with polymers.
At least they knew something
about polymers.
It's apparently, they must have
been in a drug haze at
this period in their careers.
This is absolutely terrible.
Some of your parents probably
adore the Beatles.
If you want to provoke a
conversation at Thanksgiving,
pull out this one and ask them
to talk about the lyrics here.
But this is just garbage.
This is garbage!
This should be trash bag,
is what it should be.
But evidently, this woman used
to show up at parties dressed
only in a polythene bag,
a see-through polythene
bag, I might add.
So this is a paean to her.
Anyways, it's bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway.
So here we are.
This indicates chrystalline
polyethylene.
Here you can see
the C2H4 unit.
And it's attempting to try to
occupy, as these beads line up
here, they're trying to
set up a faux lattice.
And this is what
you might see.
And towards the end of the
lecture, I'll show you a
transmission electron micrograph
where you can see
this by dying it with
different colors.
OK.
So now here's some
x-ray defraction.
So this is crystalline, where
they zoomed in on one of these
zones, and they've just
gotten the defraction
pattern from that zone.
And you see Bragg peaks.
And then this is in the
amorphous region.
it's not featureless.
There's one broad peak.
Why one broad peak?
Because even though there's no
long-range order, you have
short-range order.
You know that you've got a
carbon on either side, you've
got hydrogens and so on.
So that short range order gives
you the broad peak.
But look at C here.
Isn't this interesting?
That if you have a polymer that
has both some order and a
lot of disorder, if you take the
x-ray defraction pattern
more broadly, more globally, you
get the additive spectrum.
So you can see that this is
amorphous, but there are some
zones of crystallinity.
And that's the additivity power
of x-ray defraction that
allows us to interrogate.
So now let's talk in a little
more fine structure about
molecular architecture.
So tailoring molecular
architecture.
And why are we doing this?
Because we want to engineer
these materials for desirable
properties.
Like CD cases that break after
about one or two uses, OK?
Of polymers.
Actually, there's probably a
business opportunity there.
You start a company where
you make jewel cases
that actually work.
People might be willing to pay,
you know, a penny more
for something that works.
All right.
So how do we change this?
What I'm going to show is a
whole bunch of cartoons of
architecture.
But how do we control this?
It's processing.
Processing and in the
synthesis algorithm.
I'm assuming I already have
polyethylene, so how am I
going to tailor it?
It's in the processing.
And so what I can do, is
I've got a number of
levers I can move.
One is the composition of the
polymer, and the second one
is, I can use catalysis.
I already hinted at that last
day in talking about gasoline.
How do you start with petroleum
and get octane and
not heptane and so on?
By playing with cataylsis, we
can direct certain forms. You
can actually preferably
synthesize a certain
architecture by using
catalysts.
So let's look at these
variables.
First one is composition,
obviously.
If you change the composition
of something, you can very
much expect to change
its properties.
So what do we have here?
We can--
here's a simple example
I can start here with.
This is ethylene.
Or I can put a chlorine
here, so this now
becomes chloride, right?
This will become, what's the
radical, is vinyl, so this is
vinyl chloride.
So if I polymerize this, this
becomes polyethylene.
If I polymerize this,
this becomes
polyvinyl chloride, PVC.
Which is why you heard the
fellows from Blue Man Group at
the beginning banging on PVC
tubing to make their music.
All right.
So I use a pure, in other
words, only one mer.
It's pure polyethylene.
This it's called
a homopolymer.
Only one mer type in use.
If I want to make the polymer
analogy of an alloy--
in ally metals, alloy has more
than one metal mixed in, or a
metal can even have nonmetals
mixed in.
Then the polymer term
is called copolymer.
I'll call this a copolymer.
And a copolymer has greater
than one mer type.
So for example here, this could
just be polyethylene.
Whereas here, an example would
be polyethylene, and then the
notation is hyphen lowercase c
hyphen, which is an indication
of the fact that you're
making a copolymer.
And this copolymer has mer units
of ethylene, and mer
units of vinyl chloride.
So this is a copolymer
of polyethylene
and polyvinyl chloride.
And then we can start looking
at the various ways of
arranging these.
So we can start with, for
example, we can have a
sequence of random mer types.
So as you're going down the
chain, you get either an
ethylene, or a vinyl chloride.
So this is called a random
copolymer, and it's designated
polyethylene-r-polyvinyl
chloride.
And actually, I think I've got
a cartoon showing this.
Yeah.
So A and B are different
mer types.
And so a random copolymer
just has A, B, B,
A, A, A, B, A, whatever.
And this is controlled in
the synthesis process.
So I can take the same mix of
A and B, in other words, the
same two mer types,
but mix them in
an alternating sequence.
So they're very regular.
It's 1 mer of ethylene, and
then one mer of vinyl
chloride, alternating all the
way down the backbone.
So this gives you a regular
copolymer, and it's designated
A for alternating,
because we've
already used R for random.
So instead of a sequence of
random, we have a sequence of
alternating mer types.
So that would be, in this case,
polyethylene alternating PVC.
So that's two of them.
And then you see the block
copolymer shown.
And in that case, the
mers grouped into--
they call them blocks, even
though it's a line.
You know, maybe it's like
walking down the street.
I've walked down one block.
So this is one block, and then
there's the next block.
They're grouped into blocks.
So in that case, we have the
block copolymer, lowercase b,
and then PVC.
And what you see
there is a run.
A run of--
So all of the A's are
grouped, and then we
have all of the B's.
And this is actually an artist's
misconception.
In point of fact, most block
copolymers that you find, this
is the stuff they use for
the soles of your
sneakers and so on.
They're block copolymers.
They're usually just
a diblock.
There's usually just two
different mer types.
One half of the macromolecule
is one mer type, the other
half of the macromolecule
is the other mer type.
Sometimes you might find a
triblock, where you might find
block A, block B, and then
another block A.
But this is a pentablock and
he's even got ellipses here as
though this thing keeps going.
There's no commercial product
that looks like that.
It's usually a diblock,
occasionally a triblock.
OK?
And then the last thing you can
do, as is shown up here,
is what is known as the graft.
And in the graft, the thing that
distinguishes the graft
is mers grouped into blocks.
In this case, a long side
chain of other mer.
So that's different from side
group that we saw last day.
These are long macromolecular
chains.
So you see here the primary
backbone is A, and then you
have this very, very long
macromolecular chain of B.
And this is called the
graft copolymer.
So that would be polyethylene,
could be the backbone, and
then long side chains of
polyvinyl chloride.
And all of these have their
different architectures.
And I think I have an
example here of one.
This one, I think I mentioned
last day, when we were looking
at the butadiene.
So this is hard-sided luggage.
And if you go to grandma's
house, and she hasn't gotten
into the digital age, and isn't
an old hipster with a
cell phone, she's still got
the old hard plastic
telephone, it's made
of this stuff.
ABS, which is acrylonitrile
butadiene styrene.
And the backbone is butadiene,
and then you have--
OK, so here's the backbone.
It's long butadiene, which
we saw last day.
And then you've got side
chains of two types.
And this is just indicating
A, A, but this is a
macromolecule.
This might be 3,000 units long,
whereas this is 10,000
units long.
And this might be 2,000
So you have side chains of
acrylonitrile and side chains
of polystyrene.
And that's the hard plastic.
It's coming back, because
people want luggage that
doesn't destroy their
contents anymore.
So that's coming back.
OK.
So this is what we can do
in terms of composition.
Let's look at, also, the
side group arrangement.
And this is called tacticity.
Tacticity, which is the
equivalent of what we saw last
day as stereo isomerism.
Remember, I showed you the cis
and trans on the butadiene.
On the cis, you've got, in one
case, you've got whatever the
functional group is.
I'm going to put A, A, B, B.
And then so this is the cis
version, or I can do a trans
version, which is instead,
I'll put in A up here
and an A down here.
I'll put a B up here
and a B down here.
So this is a trans version.
So imagine the analogy
for polymers.
So let's look at that.
It's easier to see it, and then
we can just document it.
So here's three different
polymers, all right?
So I'm going to start
with the lowest one.
This is called isotactic,
because this is vinylchloride.
There's vinyl chloride
by itself.
There's the vinyl radical
from ethylene.
And then we tack on chlorine.
And now when we polymerize,
we're going to break this
double bond in order to link
this carbon to the neighbor.
So now the backbone only has
single bonds, right?
You start with the double bonded
precursor, and now
you've got this chain
of single bonds.
Right?
But look at the chlorine.
The chlorine could either be
below, or it could be above.
Well, in this case,
the chlorine is
always below the chain.
So this is called isotactic
polyvinyl chloride.
Now this one, you know, they're
trying to mix two
things at once.
I would have shown this
with vinyl chloride in
all three, but OK.
So imagine now, in this case
it's syndiotactic.
This happens to be polystyrene,
because this is
vinyl benzine, or what's
the other way to
call it, phenyl ethylene.
You can have either way.
All right?
So you can say you're putting a
phenyl group onto vinyl, or
you're putting onto the
ethylene, or vice versa.
But the radical, this thing here
is called styrene, and
we're going to break that double
bond and away we go.
So this is the benzine ring, and
it alternates from above
the chain to below the chain.
Above the chain to
below the chain.
So in this, this is called
syndiotactic.
And the top one is a
polypropylene, so you start
with propylene, that has
the double bond here.
It's got three carbons and the
methyl group coming out, and
so you break that double bond
and make the chain.
And it seems to be on a random
basis where that
methyl group appears.
Sometimes above the chain,
sometimes below the chain.
So those are three different
ways of arranging, so three
different tacticities.
So we've got isotactic, we've
got syndiotactic, and we've
got atactic.
So the way to remember them,
isotactic obviously means,
everything's on the same side.
And when I'm talking about the
same side, what is it?
Same side of the backbone.
And we're talking about
the position of
functional groups, right?
That's what this is all about.
The positioning of functional
groups.
In other words, a methyl, or a
benzine, or what have you.
So same side of backbone.
Atactic is random, and then by
elimination, this one must
mean alternating,
above and below.
On opposite sides
of the chain.
And these have different
propensities for
crystallization.
Which of these three--
imagine that all three of them
were polyvinyl chloride.
Which of the three, atactic,
syndiotactic, isotactic, would
be most favorable from the
standpoint of partial
crystallization, to loop
back and forth?
The one that's most regular,
so the isotactic one has.
OK.
Third one.
Third one is the backbone
configuration.
This is the configuration of
the main chain, all right?
And this is called
conformality.
You see, they have different
words for everything that came
from a different heritage.
So to me, it answers
the question, how
distended is the chain?
And we saw this last day, when
we looked at what happens when
we start with something like
this, where we have staggered
or eclipsed, remember,
orientation of
the hydrogens here.
In the case of staggered,
we get the lower.
Both of these are straight
chains, because if you start
at one end, you move
monotonically all the way down
the chain to the other end.
There's no branching here.
But one of them, the lower one,
has staggering of that
carbon-carbon bond, with
the result, things
form this giant loop.
So in polymers, imagine this,
instead of being 36 units
long, imagine it being
3,600 units long.
So now you can have
things to do this.
You can even take a little
break here and
crystallize and so on.
So how do I distinguish that
from something that does this?
So how distended is the chain?
This one here is as distended
as it can be, and others can
be much more coiled.
So this one is called
linear chain.
This is branch chain.
Now, this is not graft.
Don't confuse this with
the graft copolymer.
Graft copolymer means, I have
one mer down the backbone, and
a second mer off to the side.
That's a graft copolymer.
This is a homopolymer.
A homopolymer that has
different branches.
So all of these, let's put
this here to remind us.
These are homopolymer
cartoons.
Homopolymers that haven't
changed anything.
So this is something
that actually
has different branches.
So this is branched chain,
branch chain architecture.
Good.
So which one of these is going
to be harder to crystallize.
Which one is-- well, obviously,
I've given it away,
I put that little piece of
crystallinity in there.
Can you see that when these two
solidify, that the one on
the right, because it's got
these branched chains with the
covalent bonds sticking out.
It's not going to
pack as well.
And if it doesn't pack as well,
it's going to have a
higher free volume.
If it's got a higher free
volume, it's got a higher
degree of disorder.
So the branched chains
have a greater
propensity for disorder.
So let's put that down.
Branched chain, harder
to crystallize.
And crystallize, it's not a
giant crystal or polycrystal.
We're talking about the degree
to which we can get that
amount of ordering.
And then the last one I want to
show you is, here's three
different chains.
1, 2, and 3.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to cross-link.
We're going to form bridges.
These are covalent bridges.
These are not hydrogen bonds.
These are not weak van
der Walls bonds.
These are strong covalent bonds,
all the way along here,
linking backbone to backbone.
So this is cross-linked.
And what do you think the
mechanical properties of this
are going to be?
If I want extend this, like
stretch and seal, I can pull
chain number three relative to
chain number one quite easily,
until this covalent bond has
bent over as far as it can,
and then what happens?
I can't pull it anymore.
And what happens when
I let it go?
It springs back.
So this imparts elasticity.
This makes the polymer
rubbery.
Cross-linked polymers
are rubbery.
But you know, the polymer
people, they
want elevated words.
If you say to a polymer person,
oh, so you've made a
rubber, they cringe.
They want to have
a fancy word.
They call this an elastimer.
It's got the word mer in it,
so they're happy, and it's
elastic, so it's an elastimer.
Rubbery.
So how are we going to make
these cross-links?
What are we going to have to
look for as an architectural
feature to make cross-links?
We look at the backbone.
If we've got a backbone going
like this, all these
carbon-carbon bonds, and
down here I've got
carbon-carbon bonds.
If I break one of these bonds
in order to go up in this
direction, I've broken
the chain.
So how am I going to have the
bonding capability to form a
covalent bridge between chains
without breaking the very
chain I'm trying to link?
What feature am I going to have
to have in the chain?
I need, after polymerization,
to still
have some double bonds.
And if I've got still double
bonds in the backbone after
polymerization--
and now would I do that?
I have to have a double bond to
break in the first place.
So what would happen if I
started with a unit that had
two double bonds in it?
That way, I give up one double
bond in order to make the
chain, and I still have
a second double bond.
That's why the rubber
has butadiene.
The diene has two double bonds,
after polymerization,
still has one double bond, and
now what I can do is break
this double bond and this double
bond, and link them.
But if I link them,
they're going to
be too close together.
They're going to be
scrunched in.
I want to have some
play, here.
I want to make this rubbery.
So what do I do?
I put a spacer in here.
What do I use as a spacer?
An atom.
And what kind of an
atom do I need?
I need an atom that's capable
of making one,
two covalent bonds.
What am I going to choose?
What atom do you know likes
to make linkages?
How did we make silicate?
What's the linker in silicate?
Oxygen.
You could use oxygen, but I want
to make this thing even
farther apart, and a little bit,
you know, oxygen's small
and it's got too
much strength.
If I want to make it weaker,
but something that behaved
like oxygen, sulfur, I'd
go down one row in
the periodic table.
So I'd put a sulfur in here.
And if I wanted to do a really
good job, I'll put a sulfur
here, since I got a double bond
from both sides, I'll put
two sulfurs, and make a
disulfide linkage, and now
I've got the making of rubber.
Disulfide linkage.
And again, the feature, I have
to start with the backbone
that has a covalent
bond at the end.
OK.
Well, let me tell you a little
bit about the birth of rubber.
It started here in
Massachusetts.
It started just across the
river, in Roxbury.
Nathaniel Hayward discovered
that rubber treated with
sulfur was not sticky.
If you take natural rubber--
you ever work with
natural rubber?
It's very sticky.
You can't do anything with it.
And Hayward reasoned that by
playing with the sulfur, he
could-- he didn't understand
the molecular architecture.
But he learned that by playing
with sulfur, and introducing
sulfur to the rubber, he lost
the stickiness and he got an
enhanced elasticity.
So Charles Goodyear came to
Boston from Ohio to meet with
Hayward, and he learned about
disulfide linkage and so on.
Took the idea back to Ohio.
And one day in the laboratory,
he was trying to prepare a
batch of sulfonated rubber.
And it was a laboratory
accident.
He knocked over the vessel
containing this sulfonated
rubber, and it landed
on a hot stove.
Things were powered by fire.
Landed on a hot stove, and then
by heating it, he gave
birth to the process
of vulcanization.
And hence was born the American
rubber tire industry,
by that accident, starting with
the trip to Roxbury to
learn about this.
And you could have done it all
with what you learned today.
You're just about 150
years too late.
OK.
I will see you on Friday.